and it's the same one that they had  issues with the other night oh my gosh  and Kevin Love may have been watching  that game  now we have the timer on it  and starting right now there's a timeout  there's an Ishq issue  with the basketball hoop  [Applause]  I'm all showing the crowd  Doug Strauss or statman says only  explanation for this Rim was Mobley  missing all five free throws has kind of  put that Rim off kilter there you go  a lot of guys will be in there and  talking with each other and talking  [Music]  in a big game but it's a nice game  you wonder why a guy's an MVP  I mean he understands staying out and  waiting and he's out running trying to  get some Target in  Bruce Brown  see he and Murray start to get up and  down the floor a little bit